this is formula one
as a new fan of the sport watching these
races for the first time there's one
thing i couldn't help but notice
f1 drivers are all over the road
to make a left turn they go all the way
to the right of the track then swing
back left
through 90 degree corners hairpins turns
that lead into other turns and if i
learned anything in geometry it's that
the quickest path between two points is
a straight line but what do you do when
you can't take the straight line path
for race car drivers where they turn is
one part of a larger strategy based on
physics practice and a lot of skill
f1 racers drive laps through different
circuits around the world at ridiculous
speeds the highest speed they get up to
something like 215 miles per hour that's
brad philpot i've been racing since i
was eight years old and i've been
teaching people how to drive on track
for the last 15 years i think the one
area a formula one car is better than
pretty much all of the cars is cornering
speed this is important because unlike
other big motorsports like nascar which
require drivers to travel in mostly a
symmetrical oval f1 circuits contain
every kind of corner you can think of
and racers want to get through those
corners fast the racing line is purely
and simply the fastest way through a
corner or a set of corners if you had
unlimited grip and the car wasn't just
gonna roll over you would always hug the
inside you would always go the shortest
possible distance but the fact is that
the more your steering wheel is turned
the less speed your tires can cope with
hugging the inside track means you'd
have to slow down pretty severely to
avoid losing grip and sliding out
hugging the outside edge might
theoretically let you go faster but you
would be going a lot further like
massively further depending on the width
of the track and as you can see from
these f1 simulator shots brad showed me
you'd also have zero margin for error
because if you had a fraction of
understeer or oversteer you're
immediately on the grass and in the
barriers
the ideal racing line for a turn like
this is a combination of both approaches
the driver can hug the outside of the
track on the way in then turn in to clip
the apex or the center of the inside
track and end up back on the outside
edge without losing too much speed by
starting out as far wide as you possibly
can and then getting to the inside in
that smooth flowing arc you're literally
minimizing the angle that your car is
having to take which means you can carry
more speed
[Music]
so far we've been using this fake 90
degree turn example because it's simple
to explain but in real life corners
aren't that straightforward
the closest real world example is stow
on silverstone in the uk but stow isn't
really like that normal typical 90
degree corner it is a bit longer you
reach the apex of stowe and you're there
for a little while at least a few tenths
of a second if not a second or so so you
still feel like you're kind of hugging
the inside for a while but you are
definitely taking pretty much that
typical line we spoke about you can see
that in this clip from the 2022 grand
prix carlos signs leads the pack and
takes this nearly textbook ideal racing
line but most corners are a little more
complicated a corner does not exist in
isolation so the racing line you take
for a particular corner is almost always
a compromise take this set of corners
from that same silverstone circuit
brooklyn's is the super tight one and it
goes straight into left field you're at
the end of a very long fast straight you
then end up in a sweeping
left-hander where it gets tighter all
the way around and it's then followed by
a really long right-hander so judging by
what we've been discussing so far you'd
probably say that you need to compromise
your exit a little bit in the
left-hander so you wouldn't go all the
way wide however in this example you do
almost the counter-intuitive thing based
on what we've already been learning left
field which is the second corner the
right-hander is a very very long
right-hander well over 180 degrees it
nullifies most of the benefit you would
get from going wide and then cutting
back towards it it's not an apex that
you kiss like in our 90 degree right
hander example you meet the inside and
you have to stay there by trying to
compromise the initial left-hander
you're actually just wasting time you're
wasting distance and this is why this is
such a complicated thing it doesn't have
an easy answer you can see all drivers
having a slightly different approach to
this particular set of corners in this
clip from the 2022 grand prix
while the leading car tries to use the
most ideal path hugging the curves the
following cars are more spread out and
did you catch that these two cars almost
collided and to avoid it this driver
went off the track screwing up his
racing line entirely once you have to
contend with other drivers racing lines
become a lot more complex what you have
to do is compromise based on the track
that's available to you so you're still
going to be going outside inside outside
as much as you can but that will be on
maybe half the track width if the
weather is wet and rainy that adds even
more complexity racers may compromise
their line even further in search of
areas of the track that have more grip
formula one drivers are constantly
making calculations to adapt to any
condition and still maintain a good
racing line
and they can do that because they're not
thinking of the line as they're driving
they just do it if i went to pretty much
every f1 track even tracks i've never
actually been to before
i would probably know pretty much
where i want the car to be from driving
on simulators or watching videos and all
that kind of thing so it's not a guess
once race day arrives with all its
variables and rivalries the focus is no
longer on ideals it's on the strategic
compromises a racer is willing to make
to get ahead of the competition that's
really what separates drivers you've got
various inputs that you're making as a
driver throttle input braking steering
changing gear communicating with pits
conversing with your engineers strategy
but the biggest one of all of those is
the steering it is the line you're
taking
[Music]
[Music]
you